vocês costumam guardar alimentos em
recipientes de plástico ou bebem água em
garrafa plástica pessoal que tal
repensar isso a alternativa mais segura
é usar vidro cerâmica ou aço inoxidável
por que que eu tô falando isso
recomendando isso vamos lá em um estudo
bem interessante 93% do total de 259
garrafas de água testadas apresentaram
microplásticos pequenas partículas de
plástico que embora não se saiba a certo
como afeta a nossa saúde sabemos que
podem agir como esponjas absorvendo
substâncias nocivas como é o caso de
metais pesados poluentes persistentes ou
até mesmo microrganismos que causam
doenças outro grande problema é que
esses microplásticos estão cheios de
cheno estrogênio que imita o hormônio
feminino do nosso corpo hormônio
estrogênio o que pode levar a problemas
metabólicos e hormonais tanto em
mulheres como em homens